[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my fifth episode of killer
miniature straps
in today's episode we are going to look
at three different
surprising opening traps and the content
are as follow
well the first one is very interesting
one as
after the king's gambit e4
e5 and the mo f4 we have this
very surprising pentel jackie's gambit
starting with f5
and i'm sure a lot of your opponent get
a root shock
because this move is hardly been covered
in any theoretical manual
well the first blunder white can play
over here is f captures e5
and you will be surprised that as per
the leeches database
there are more than 3500 games
goes with the silly move where
black instantly finished the game with
queen check g3 and after queen captures
e4
you can see that clearly black gobbled
up the rook
just within the opening stage
so f captures ifa is a big time blunder
here
the main move is e captures f5
and after this we sets up another
cunning trap
and that is queen to e7
so our idea is very simple we want to
take on f4
and provide a discover check and
believe me there are only two good moves
here for the watch
one is knight to f3 and the second is
queen to h5 check
as happened in many cases there are more
than 300 leeches games
continue with f captures e5
which looks very logical
[Music]
white gobble up yet another pawn
and if you take on e5 then he can block
it
with his own queen well i'm afraid
black has tricked the white once again
as
we are going to give the check by not
taking on e5
but our favorite square yup
h4 so that if g3
then we nap the rook in the corner and
funny enough
white most frequent choice here is king
to e2
which i think leads to a quick mate
i just like to show you my recent
victory in this line
where i continue with some obvious moves
queen to e4 jack
king to f2 bishop to cfa check
my opponent tried to develop his dark
squad bishop by sacrificing upon d4
bishop captures d4 king to g3
now i take on e4 forcing king back to f2
and again giving this check and finally
when king goes to g3 the nasty move
knight to e7 and surprisingly
there is actually very few defenses
exist
well the game finished very quickly he
played queen to h5 jack
i played g6 and after f captures g6
can you see a forcing checkmate
please pause the video and find out if
you need more time
i am showing you right now queen check
king to f3 black castles
king to g4 d5
king to g5 rook to f5 king to h6
and now the lovely bishop to g7
finish the white king dance
now before we leave i'd like to quickly
point out that queen to h5 jack
doesn't refute this variation because
even though
black king has been misplaced after the
following popular choices such as
f captures e5 queen captures e5
bishop to e2 we gain time by attacking
this queen
and considering the most frequently
played move
queen to f3 black has this nice sequence
which even get slight advantage with
knight to c6 c3 and now
d5 whereupon white's best move is
d4 and after that yup
you guessed it queen captures f5
queen captures f5 and bishop f5
at the end of transaction not only black
get his material back
but if you carefully look at this black
has a superior peace development
which gives him a slight advantage
the second trap is one of my favorite
one
as currently i'm playing this line
regularly
in my blitz games which occurs
in the fajarvis gambit which arises
after the following move order
d4 knight to f6 c4
and now you play e5
okay white took it and now
knight to g4 leads to the budapest
gambit
but black has another surprising move
knight to e4 known as fajarvis
campet well the most of the ideas
are related to quick fast development
and one of it is bishop to b4 check
so many white players try to block this
jack
first with a3 and after
our true gambit play with d6
one of the most frequent choice by the
white camp is
to capture this pawn first and after
bishop takes d6
continue with knight to f3 which is
in fact as per the leeches database
played in more than 1200 games
would you believe after this white is
completely losing
so before we move on i like you to pause
this video and find out
a killer move which wins the game for
the black
on the spot
are you ready did you find this deciding
move
boom
what a move well clearly black is
attacking two major guys so white
response is forced
he has to take on f2 but after this
i am sure you see that white is losing
the queen
with this wonderful bishop jack which
closed the door for the white king
and forces him to capture yet another
piece
but at the end when you get his queen
if you count the material black get
whole queen for two minor pieces which
is of course
close to winning so this is one of the
high profile
queen trap exist in the fajaras gambit
which even many strong players has
fallen into
the third trap occurs against the
specific
job london system structure where
white commits the early knight to f3
let me show you what i mean d4
knight to f6 here white can choose
either knight c3 or bishop f4
let's say in this game bishop to f4
happened first
and after our e6 white plays
knight to c3 well against this
one of my favorite line is the queen's
indian structure
starting with b6 and
in order to achieve our trap white has
to play this move in the row
so for example after knight to f3
black plays bishop to b4 pinning down
this knight
and e3 is one of the most
frequent choice
well guess what yup we have achieved
our trappy platform and again if you
check the leaches database
there are more than 150 games goes
into this direction which i'm afraid
are losing mistake by the white camp
as black has the winning shot here
starting with knight to e4
so as you can see there is a double
attack on c3
and the only way to defend this knight
is
by playing queen to d3
which defends as well as attack on e4
but after black's next reply f5
no matter how waver white plays
he is completely busted
as i have shown here a3 and bishop to e2
are the most frequent choice but against
each of them
our reply is very consistent
first bishop to e2 big time mistake
and i know you already see what black is
up to
yup bishop to a6 double attack
queen has to go to d1 after this
the task is very easy first you capture
this bishop
and when white recapture you take on c3
white dare not to touch this knight
because if we take it then after bishop
c3
we get the rook on the even square and
just within the 11th move of the game we
are
hold rook up
so that will happen if your opponent
continue with
bishop to e2 the second choice is
a3 which is neither good as well
because once again we deliver
bishop to a6 forcing
queen to go back to d1
and i think black has to be careful in
this position
because if you continue with knight
captures c3
then queen to d2 is a very strong reply
so that's why the correct response here
is
first you take this knight with the
bishop
and after pawn takes now you take on
c3 attacking the queen and
when the queen goes anywhere let's say
queen to c1
we take on f1 completely ruin
the castle of white and after we castle
if you carefully look at this position
not only black is a clear pawn
up but white king is completely
caught at the center
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
three high profile opening mini traps
you can literally use them regularly
in your online blitz sessions or it can
be utilized
as a complete surprise weapon in the
tournament practice
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe
and comment and i will meet you in my
next episode
very soon bye and take care